did you start your software
okay thanks i do have one thing to say
and that's that podcasting before
11
is really unnatural
yeah it feels a little weird i mean i've
been up for a little bit because my dad
was just here i had breakfast with him
so i've been up for a little bit
i've had some conversations with about
this and people say oh i get my best
ideas in the morning when i wake up
fresh and other people are like no i
have my best ideas at night when i'm a
night owl all my ideas come when it's
dark and i feel kind of
more inside well most people become
podcasters so they don't have to wake up
early but it seems like all of us were
up before
nine o'clock
yeah i was up about 9 20. i got up at
seven but that's because i had to bring
my cat to the vet so
well i was up at 6 30
and i don't know if it came from my
dream or not but i awoke with this
fully fledged idea of a delizzo
guitarian mind as a mushroom and i
couldn't get back to sleep because i was
too excited about it
what
you'll have to wait for the meat on that
for later victor
it might be total [ __ ] like 80 of my
ideas are total [ __ ] but twenty percent
they land so
by the way let's get this started
[Music]
all right welcome listeners we're on the
pill pod 80
[ __ ] 83
something like that
just say all the numbers and cut the
right one in 84 right 82 83 84. it's one
of those i'm pretty it's not 82 i don't
think
um i thought we thought
that the pill pod
could use some serialization just a dash
because we've done a lot of non-serial
episodes and in the past we've done
different series
uh the fight night comes to mind did we
what are other series that we've done
phenomenology i guess was this year yeah
yeah some side series i guess you could
call the interviews a kind of running
series
yeah kind of but they're pretty
unrelated often no thematically
unrelated but the format is yeah
we thought we needed to get back to the
series the serialization so
we need some continuity we are doing
communism hmm
nice actually
not actually existing communism but the
idea
of communism so not even marxism
specifically but we have these two idea
words in the title idea
and communism but they don't matter
though right pills
well i guess we'll see remains to be
seen yeah it's it's our it's a test of a
a long-standing trope on the show that
ideas don't matter maybe maybe this one
does well bad deuce says
i mean this is pre pre prefacing but he
does say if you don't have a truth
procedure your idea by itself doesn't
matter so right he agrees with me
i don't remember that caveat in your in
your statement
there was always an asterisk sorry matt
what were you saying oh no i was going
to say uh i was going to come on and be
relatively critical um of elements of
this article today uh that was my plan i
had a few things written up but then
last night i wanted to see jurassic
world dominion
and i realized that everything adorno
said about the culture industry was not
only right but actually inadequate
now i've committed myself to the
complete liquidation of the market
system because if you can't even get a
dinosaur movie done properly then
there's just no hope for it and we have
to radically transform the system
immediately like tomorrow or even
yesterday it really would have been
better
that's it just go see movies and you
will be a communist after jurassic world
is the one thing that radicalizes why
did you go see him my wife really likes
the jurassic park
she's been a
one of those like kind of long-standing
fans who appreciate the franchise is
dumb
or has become dumb but just wants to see
it and and by the way it is
spectacularly dumb anyone who is a fan
of chris pratt back in the parks and rec
days should be extremely disappointed in
all of the things he's done since except
maybe guardians but you know
middling
anyway idea
of communism they're both in the title
idea this is a philosophy word that
stretches all the way back to the origin
of political philosophy
at least
and uh communism which was first
i think it's like an outgrowth of
enlightenment political philosophy a
french
i don't remember remember his name but a
french guy said it first began
identifying as a communist
but of um it's mostly marx what did you
say his name was
uh fourier was that him
i don't know it was
end of the
18th century yeah dates match up oh
interesting i i could have sworn he had
a
d
in his surname but maybe that's it
so our series today and following will
be on we don't have it set in stone
totally but we
maybe i'm speaking for us maybe i'm
speaking for myself but
actual power seems unassailable these
days and
nominal democratic representation
through
electoral politics we have very little
agency and it feels like
it's it's not going anywhere it's not
increasing though even without political
agency we do have some agency when it
comes to what we think
yeah well i mean i think it's always
been the case i mean i don't know if any
i don't know if there's ever been a time
when people were really like
empowered
like like really
uh it does seem particularly it does
seem particularly like bad right now
um to a certain extent but like how do
you like say more pills like like in
what way do you feel uh
well outside of a few
union unionization efforts that are
being met with some success that are
super exciting besides that it feels
like as a western left
the only thing we ever have to hope for
is bernie running again is like the
limit of any
imaginative faculty that we have about a
future that looks different from the
president
i should say that these kind of pieces
were very very popular uh in the
aftermath of 2008. uh it's not just this
one this is one of the more famous
examples of it and then after 2016 you
had a bunch of articles come out talk
about why democratic socialism was
resurging and i think what all these
demonstrate and by the way i fall into
this paradigm is a desire for a genuine
political alternative
to what we could call
the liberal tradition or the liberal
capitalist tradition but one that
retains its most progressive elements uh
without abandoning them to revanchism
reactionarism whatever you want
conservatism postmodern searches and
whatever you want to call it and i
absolutely uh accept uh this kind of
yearning for an alternative because i do
see it as an expression of what
socialists have always called a desire
for social freedom uh the ability to
kind of remake the world uh in line with
our image which itself would mean that
would be less alienated now how to go
about doing that and which kind of model
we should follow as we all know uh the
left tends to divide
pretty much every second minute or so on
those questions
the this that matt is talking about has
not been introduced yet yeah exactly so
i will introduce it now the this that
matt is referring to is the idea of
communism which is a book actually three
books
from three conferences since 2009. so
this is back to the
uh post 2008 housing crisis that's
caused that little little meltdown thing
and attending these conferences
sold out conferences
where a bunch of academics including the
most famous living marxists you could
think of for the most part i don't think
david harvey was that at least the first
one but
um zizek badu
terry eagleton susan buck morris rancier
negri i could go on
nancy you could get yeah
so hard we thought we'd bounce around
these conference books because there's a
bunch of
punchy short ideas put in article form
that come from the papers they presented
at these conferences
we thought we'd see what's up what's
relevant
as since
since 2009
everything feels a little bit worse
especially with the uh
the the brexit the trump the
reactionary
right conspiracy etc etc so
we are here to bring you a couple
episodes on
well [ __ ] what
communism yeah the question that we ask
ourselves every morning when we get up
could the world of tomorrow be better
than today instead of worse alternatives
alternatives
alternatives to the shitty thing that we
have right now i will say also for the
listener
i don't know when they'll be listening
to this i guess but right now i'm just
noticing on verso they have a 30 off
sale all their books so if you want you
can get the idea of communism from verso
press for 30 off right now yeah we're
starting and we're starting in volume
one and there's three volumes
i only own two of them so i might have
to get that third one
i'd just like to share someone i'm using
anecdote about one of the editors of the
spasm costas dooziness uh because costas
was actually gonna be my supervisor once
upon a time but i met him later on in
2015 and
he's actually the reason i'm married now
of all things
because i was hanging out with costas
and his wife when we were talking
because i was at the conference and my
future wife although i didn't know it
was there with me and when costas wife
disappeared he turned and looked at both
of us and was like
okay she's gone here's 10 pounds i need
you to go buy me a pack of smokes right
now make sure she does not know about it
then come back and you know i'll get you
a beer or something and lo and behold me
and my future wife went on our first
walk together to go buy cigarettes for
costa's dooziness avoided his wife at
all costs brought them back and we
talked about that for the rest of the
night so you're funny you're you're
outing cost is do using us as as
secretly smoking behind his wife's back
on a public podcast yeah hopefully she's
not listening completely she's not
listening
look at the beautiful thing that came
out of it how could they be mad yeah we
didn't get communism but we got matt
married um yeah so costas dizziness and
are the editors of these volumes so
thank you tobacco to bring people
together exactly
right to a cigarette company it's like
youtube
anyway we have to we have to start on
this question
the the politics theorists which is
victor and matt half of this podcast
what right to you
as self-identified liberals
have to talk about communism and why
should we listen to you on this
when you don't believe this [ __ ]
well i don't think i i don't not believe
it
i think that we do need alternatives
um i don't think by the way this is not
my question to you this is a question
that
about about five to ten percent of our
listening audience will have of you
we're heading it off
is that what they and also like i mean
who do no because they don't if they
haven't heard us they don't understand
your version of liberalism so this is
your chance to uh to wash your hands of
the dirty liberalism
i mean yeah i would say that for me you
know like it's not so much that i'm
committed to all the
all the implications of kind of like the
the caricature of liberal
liberalism that um you know anti-liberal
communists have uh just like i think it
would be stupid to be a liberal and base
your critiques of communism on the like
shitty caricatures and in fact speaking
of shitty characters for my tutorial in
the class i'm teeing this summer
actually just before this had to read uh
sections of frederick hayek's the road
to serfdom where he presents very very
good example of like a shitty caricature
of communism as being like this
centralized planned thing with like no
freedom of any kind it's like well
that's not necessarily
uh that doesn't necessarily you know
encompass all the possibilities of what
communism means
but if you base your critiques of
communism on what frederick hayek says
then i think you're really missing out
and i think similarly if you're going to
base your critiques of liberalism on
like what neoliberalism has done then
you're missing out on like the potential
emancipatory
uh possibilities that at least uh some
ideas in liberalism have so i think it's
not so much that i'm a committed liberal
as much as i am
committed to avoiding caricatures
of ideological positions and taking what
are good ideas from each
and accepting those things without being
worried that oh my god i'm contaminated
by like liberal ideas that's just a
stupid intellectual way of thinking
about things
um so i'm i'm really not for one
ideology as much as i am taking the good
ideas from the various things that make
sense which is why i'm excited to read
uh the different ideas uh of communism
that will come up in this series i guess
you could summarize that as a kind of uh
syncretist
political position
maybe a left-leaning syncretism very
left-leaning and as stupid as hayek's
criticisms of of
marxism are they're not even they don't
hold a candle to james lindsay's
criticisms
according to james lindsey marxism is
gnosticism which is just about the
stupidest sentence i could string
together with a random text generator
yeah you know i will say and i i will
say that like hayek's
criticisms like i do think that like he
does do a good job of criticizing
centralized planning like i think i
think centralized planning is probably a
bad idea
but i don't think most communists or
socialists
are for centralized planning i think
that's a pretty like fringe position but
anyway we're talking about yeah idea of
communism not actually existing
communism
why are you allowed to talk about
marxism or communism well like my short
answer would be if you're gonna lodge as
stupid an argument as that towards me
internet people then i'm just gonna
throw it right back at you and be like
well why are you allowed to talk about
liberalism [ __ ] you know
don't begin bringing any kind of red
[ __ ] around me but no you know if
you want to have a more sophisticated
conversation about it i identify as a
democratic socialist and a liberal i
think those two things actually go
together very well uh and you know we've
already hashed out why it is that i
think marx's approach to liberalism is
more sympathetic uh than a lot of the
more
ultra leftist uh would give him credit
for yeah go listen to the go listen to
the own the libs episode if you want to
hear more about matt and i's position on
liberalism yeah that's a good one
uh so i'm not going to rehash that whole
thing yeah look you know i'm sympathetic
like i said to a lot of this book's
ambitions which is articulating i think
above all else a desire
for an alternative that carries the best
features of liberalism forward while
chucking all the [ __ ] uh and
creating something communism yeah that's
great well this is what i'm gonna get
creating something new uh that's stamped
by the best features of the old right to
use the marxist term in the critique of
the gotha program uh and i prefer to
associate with democratic socialism and
part of the reason for that as i think
both politically and rhetorically
there's a lot more gas in that label
than in the communist label because
people tend to associate democratic
socialism a little bit more with the
nordic model for example which has been
extremely successful uh or you know a
variety of west uh european social
democratic or socialist parties that
have implemented some good stuff if you
want to identify as a communist and you
think that that label has a little bit
more traction to it uh than the
democratic socialist one i'd be open to
listening maybe i could identify as a
liberal communist and just piss off even
more people
but i've yet to be convinced uh by that
see we have this problem where you keep
going to reality the whole point is the
idea of communism the idea of communism
all right so let's talk about these
conferences just briefly before we read
uh badu's entry into the conferences
this book was are these books this one
specifically volume one came out
immediately after the bank bailout um
austerity measures were kind of being
the solution to the financial crisis
especially in the eu and from what i've
noticed the talks in this book are
kind of optimistic maybe
more optimistic than they would have
been uh
post post-trump and and post-brexit
because z-jack writes in the intro quote
the collapse of the banking system in
2008 marked the beginning of a return to
full-blown
history
so eric i know you looked into this uh
did i get everything or what i leave out
nothing else you mentioned i mean that
it was that it was so popular that the
venue had to be moved i think two or
three times to get more room for people
it was it was like a sold out event it
was probably the
i don't know the biggest event
discussing ideas of communism in since
the arts um
i read an article on the guardian that
was released around this time when
they're like the hottest ticket in
london this weekend isn't just miserable
or to go see you know i think it was
like oasis but a conference on communism
with such firebrands as terry eagleton
and slap on g-check and i'm like that is
pretty a weird thing to think like yeah
and and the the reviews you see of the
conference really do focus on the
performative aspects of it they love to
sort of comment minutely on g-x sort of
kind of overbearing outwardly directed
energy
they love to comment on the sort of
overall
spectacle-ness of the whole event um
i think i think it's a little bit of uh
you know mainstream
news doesn't know what to do with this
in a certain way what category to slot
it in so they end up sort of doing a
kind of aesthetic aestheticized
description of it
but apparently this is zizek at his
frenetic best
yeah and
the other conference members said they
didn't mind his overbearingness because
of the sort of energy that it was
bringing to the table
in any case i'll just quote from the
intro one last time this is the their
version of the purpose the thesis of the
conference
quote the key question addressed is
whether communism is still the name to
be used to designate radical
emancipatory projects the conference
participants although coming from
different perspectives and projects
shared the thesis that one should remain
faithful to the name communism
end quote
faithful to the name i guess since we're
since we're reading uh one of badu's
entries into this whole thing he kind of
says right at the beginning not of this
article but in his forward to the
program of the conference
he says the communist hypothesis remains
the good one i don't see any other if we
have to abandon this hypothesis then it
is no longer worth doing anything at all
in the field of collective action
without the horizon of communism without
this idea
there is nothing in the historical and
political becoming of any interest to a
philosopher
let everyone bother about their own
affairs and let us stop talking about it
what is imposed on us as a task even as
a philosopher philosophical obligation
is to help a new mode of existence of
the hypothesis to deploy itself okay so
it's a hypothesis an idea
it's not about actual existing communism
it's about
a sort of a horizon yeah it's about a
horizon it's about working to the
realization of the idea working towards
some future
point where the idea will be realized
and this event will be
kind of a
what will have been
in terms of the history of that event
so with that why don't we just kick off
the series i we have not talked about
bed use so i just want to give a a note
on him i don't know why we haven't
talked about bad you because matt's
matt's been itching too
um but if we want to define him
cursorily
is chris sorry a word
yes okay good anyway are you ready for
this badu
i wrote is a platonist maoist math
realist
so if you ever wanted a combination of
mathematics platonism and maoism
i don't know if anyone has ever asked
for that but here's your guy
it's a wholly unique con combination and
i know it's bad to use a modifier on the
word unique but it is wholly unique
um last time we did bring him up was
briefly in the uh may 68 episode
because he was part of this faction of
maoists at paris eight who are known for
breaking through the ceilings looking
for cia microphones
he was one of those
but his philosophy is really like
nothing else and mad i'm really sorry
but i do not want to get into the math
realism here because he doesn't bring it
up and i don't really know anything
about set theory
and uh
but he doesn't bring it up in this talk
anyway so
thankfully but he does bring up
something that i know the political
theorists among us know very well which
is the idea of the good
um and that communism is the idea of the
good which i don't think is how plato
necessarily meant it but if we choose to
commit to it
to be subject to it that is what it
means to be a philosopher today only you
are if you're a communist or if you're a
philosopher
you are actually a communist
um and listen i just want to begin by
explaining the arguments the second half
you can offer your challenges i know
you're itching to it but let's try to uh
figure out
how is the horizon of the good in
political theory now
communism
well i i do think it is important to
make one note about his ontology and i
agree with you let's put all the math
stuff aside right um because one of the
things that he agrees with people like
zizek or khan about is this idea that
reality has a kind of incompleteness to
it a lot of western thought has been
about trying to
describe reality as some kind of
totality right which he expresses in a
number of different ways you know
describe it as one if you want to use
the mathematical term and his argument
is that his interpretation of set theory
proves that you can't describe reality
in this kind of way uh it's always
defined by multiplicities and the reason
why politically this is important uh is
various forms of ideology and the state
try to insist that actually we have
settled on the right kind of politics
and we will become one society by
committing ourselves to this kind of
political agenda right
and then things will more or less roll
along the way that they have forever
without any substantial changes
sorry to interrupt but if you do want to
read this article i'll attach it to
to in patreon and make it public so even
if you're not interested in becoming a
patron you can still have a look at it
with my highlights sorry i accidentally
saved it with the highlights so
i'd also say if people are interested in
getting into badger but they don't want
to read three volumes of being an event
right now because the little book
conditions is about 300 pages or so and
it summarizes his entire position
it's a very short little introduction
written by him that kind of gives you
all the basics
right so
where do we begin i mean the
the idea of communism is important
because what we seem to have is
capitalism
which offers
which itself claims to be the only way
forward there's no alternatives
and yet in the history of capitalism
we've seen these enormous
gulfs of inequality arise the
concentration of wealth i mean the the
pretense of this conference is you know
is again another quote from the intro
the the 2008 bailout of the banks to the
tune of over a trillion dollars
socialized the losses of neoliberal
casino capitalism so it took
the gambling with our economy that has
happened in neoliberal casino capitalism
which i interpret as you know what
emerged with you know reagan and
thatcher and and the neoliberals of the
70s and 80s
the sort of neoliberal which also
implies deregulation and cutting social
safety nets and
the
apparently the socialization of risks
right where
we get a situation with the common
phrase you know socialism for the banks
or socialism for the rich and capitalism
for the poor and everybody else
so there's a certain
idea
here
the idea of communism that can repair
the sort of fractured solidarity of the
human race right we've become fractured
we've become
uncaring
and neoliberalism pose imposes
a kind of cynicism
on us and that's part of the reason why
you know communism isn't the only
philosophically interesting idea because
if you don't take it seriously then you
just kind of give in to the status quo
neo-liberalism and you become
subordinated to the state and the sort
of compulsory cynicism that comes along
with that which is to say you know it's
poor people's fault they're poor africa
is a backward place
like you know those sorts of thinking
that we still commonly encounter even in
2022
which is that the world if it's not with
us then it's completely backwards and
[ __ ] up and it's their own fault in a
way
despite
you know
we know about the histories of
capitalism and colonialism and
imperialism and yet still it's somehow
the subject the subject's fault that
they are in their state of destitution
so i mean what do we do we look to the
idea of communism not actually existing
communism but the hypothesis of
communism as a unifying idea
we'll all have different ideas of it
individually but it's something that we
can kind of through which we can join
into a collective movement
and do you think that this
this idea of communism like it sounds
kind of like it's playing a role
i mean of
a kind of like universal good which is
kind of interesting because it seems to
me that like often these theorists want
to like resist
being committed
to an idea of a universal good but it
kind of seems like they're that's what
this is doing so like
well we'd have to get into his actual
definition of idea because it's a very
yeah i do yeah it's a very idiosyncratic
general in the in the in the volume like
i was actually looking quickly at the
introduction as well which i think it's
kind of worth
mentioning
like at the like it's just like four
pages uh introduction by the two editors
and i think they say you know they have
like four points to kind of say um
you know without any particular the
shared premises that brought most people
together so it doesn't include all of
them right and there's like four things
and this is actually pretty important to
get into before we even touch on this
thing about idea because um he does
think that there is a universalistic
dimension uh to this but in a very
particular way that flows from his
ontology and it's related back to this
idea of an event right when you see a
rupture in the order of let's just call
it political being right uh there is the
opportunity to engage in the possibility
of creating new possibilities right uh
but then and this is an idea he gets
from kierkegaard and st paul he wrote a
pretty interesting book on saint paul
actually where he says you have a choice
then uh you can either choose to show
fidelity to this rupture in the order of
fidelity of political being and try to
create something new a kind of faith
right uh or you can choose to not show
fidelity to that uh and to commit
yourself to upholding the status quo
ideology whatever it happens to be but
he does think it's an existential choice
right and other people will decide to
make the other one and say no i'm
sticking with what i have right now
in summary everybody has a choice to
either accept or reject communism and
there's not a middle ground just like
you have a choice to accept
be complicit with or reject
capitalism
um so the idea itself represents
it's
so there's three parts to the idea this
is getting into his little definition
thing
um it is historical in that it keeps
appearing and he brings up examples of
it appearing the idea which is the
french revolution the peoples were in
china the russian revolution they're all
aimed at a political truth which is
emancipation however
that doesn't exhaust the idea because
the idea is not just history the idea is
also a truth procedure and unlike many
of his compatriots he's very committed
or as matt said
he has a fidelity to the idea of truth
and the point is unlike and i think you
could say unlike uh
unlike other marxists as well
history is not the source of this
so communism is this horizon and it
demands that you make a decision
and when you make a decision then you
become a subject and you become a
subject of a political truth whether
that's capitalism whether that's
communism so there's no bench sitters i
think is a good way to say it for for
bed you you either you either affirm
reality as it is or you affirm reality
as it is not
communism is not reality it's impossible
and because it's impossible then it's
possible one of the things that he
argues that's related to marx is that
with hegel
maybe with kent he sometimes flirts with
both of them you saw this transition to
the idea that history
and aesthetics is where meaning can be
found and he says you know you see the
people who lean towards aesthetics with
people like nietzsche schopenhauer
people lean towards history with hegel
marx all them right uh and he says that
both of them are wrong right we need to
go back to a platonic conception of
truth uh that's more ancient and more
correct uh but he doesn't want to
abandon all the achievements of marxist
materialism
and historicism he just wants to
reconfigure it in the way that he's
thinking of it did you see where he said
in here um you cannot believe in hegel
unless you do it like my friend zizik
you need it you must have a new hegel
you can't repeat hegel though because
his idea is like emergent in history
exactly i mean they've had a really
productive dialogue on this point and
there's no doubt that veggie's influence
kind of pushed
gg in the way of creating this kind of
negative
scatological
hegel but you know you can think about
this kind of classical marxist narrative
that you'd find in somebody like
although it was also a big influence
where it says where you'd say you know
we have our science of history it proves
that communism is coming communism is
the answer to the riddle of history to
use the marxist phrase right
so just commit yourself to that
and everything is going to become better
but
strongly rejects that right where he
says that we need to understand history
symbolically right
and one of the ways to do this is with
this idea of proper names which
designate matt you're term dropping too
fast
sorry i mean we need to understand
history uh as
not something that's set in any given
direction and needs to be understood
symbolically right history and the
meaning we find in history comes from us
um and then he leans into his
laconianism to try to explain that so we
can get into that later sorry
yeah so i mean we can keep doing passes
because
you know the idea of communism forbegi
has these three basic elements as we
mentioned there's a political dimension
a historical dimension
and a subjective dimension
and i just mentioned right off the bat
that subjective does not imply
individual no no subjective
doesn't mean an individual
although an individual can make
themselves a subject that is they can
subjectivate
which is basically again his line here
is to
to decide
to you can decide to become part of a
political truth procedure
right and a political truth procedure is
is simply a kind of practice right truth
emerges from practice and practice is is
a concrete
practice
time specific sequence right so he
brings up you know the french revolution
the people's war of liberation in china
and some other examples
now these
these are political
and they are empirical
there are
kinds of records of of
what we call truth procedures
and they relate to history
because history again is is a kind of
universal thing right it's not simply
you know history we commonly say you
know history is what was written down
that's why we have the word pre-history
before writing was invented but in this
case history is the general becoming of
humanity it's our collective history as
human beings which are punctuated
by these political
situations
and we have to grasp these
truth procedures
in their proper places in history which
is the symbolic
and we decide to become a part of them
in a certain sense right so joining the
collective body of truth in a certain
way is to decide and to decide in that
way is to become a subject
and to reject is to withdraw is is not
to enter into it to withdraw into your
own private selfhood
as opposed to becoming a kind of
collective subject
so those three elements keep
kind of circulating and reappearing
throughout his argument ideas the
totalization of these three basic
elements truth procedure belonging to
history and individual subjectivation
which is again to become part of a
broader body of truth
and the collective subject you could
i mean you can't conflate it with but
one of the the names of the collective
subject is
marx's working class
but for badu communism is more like a
humanity project so you can choose to
identify with the goals of humanity
or you choose not to and i thought it
was really interesting when he says we
have these communist heroes but the
communist heroes are only guises of the
idea
so he names like all the way back to
spartacus
lenin
rosa luxemburg che guevara and he said
the only reason that we have
individual heroes is because you need
like a body to identify with to
subjectivate yourself with but the only
reason that these are heroes is because
they are like
a guise of the idea which is supposed to
represent everybody like a free a free
humanity by their writings or what they
did or whatever it is so there's no it's
anti-individualist in that sense
well that's also where i start to get
him a little bit wary of what uh he
argues because he wrote a truly terrible
he had a truly terrible interview about
his maoism uh where when people pointed
out to him that mal might have killed a
few people uh in his time just a few he
said well that's just exaggerated
western propaganda surely it wasn't 60
million it could have been more than a
few million and i'm like really you know
that that's your
creme de la creme argument it wasn't
tens of millions it was millions at most
come on dude but and anyway i do think
that his theory of history though has a
lot going for it uh i prefer the
or the zizekian kind of reformulation of
it maybe because i'm a bit of a hegelian
at heart but i mean this idea that
being is multiplicity that every kind of
human society has tried to ignore that
by establishing a faux totality
instantiating it within that political
system and inevitably there's a rupture
that you can choose to show fidelity to
uh or not and become the subject
of
the possibility of possibilities uh by
joining with
other people i think it's quite an
inspiring and i do think that
he is right that if we're going to
reconceptualize something like marx's
materialism it needs to be understood on
these lines because i just don't think
anybody's going to buy into
a teleological vision of materialist
history anymore it's just not going to
happen right right and i think he kind
of gets around the claims that you know
there were horrors under stalinism there
are horrors under maoism
precisely by saying you know communism
isn't just
a political name it can't be a purely
political name
because you know what what happened
happened in those
situations
but the idea of communism kind of
persists and even even though today we
have kind of no actually existing
communism
except maybe china which has
mixed itself in with capitalist ideas in
obvious ways
so but but with the disappearance of
actually existing communism what is left
we have global capitalism so is that the
only way to go then
and the answer has to be no
for this idea to succeed and i think
it's important that he does
i i mean this is probably a strategy but
it's saying
i i haven't heard the reference that
matt's making but he does refer here to
like uh stalin's terror
and saying
the terror of stalin does not exhaust
the idea because the idea has to be
outside what any
so-called
political communist ever did
which is you know strategically good
because
they do bad stuff but it's true that uh
there's there's no alternative to
capitalism except for
like this if you if you buy this uh
thesis yeah yeah and i'm only to say
that he's okay on that i mean if we're
gonna forgive liberalism for all the
horrors that it's committed uh or at
least say that there's something left to
the label then he's entitled to make a
similar kind of claim right
what i think would make me more
convinced by some of his arguments uh is
badger shares this kind of continental
and victor maybe you'll sympathize with
this uh wariness of engaging in what he
calls political theory uh what he calls
regression to political theory saying
this is what we should do these are the
kind of institutions we should have
these are the kind of movements we
should be killed because he's very
committed to this historical
idea that the event uh will reveal the
kind of falsity of the established order
and you can choose to show fidelity to
it and emancipate yourself or not right
it's a very argument that operates at
this very ontological level and it's
very hard for me not at points to think
that
it would be helpful
to have at least a few programs
available about what it is that we're
going to replace the political order
being with when the time comes he kind
of says this so i was gonna bring up
this quote uh from uh at the end of page
eight to nine he starts talking about uh
he's like it's incumbent upon uh upon
the communist idea to respond to the
question where do just ideas come from
the way mao did just ideas and by this i
mean what constitutes the path of a
truth in a situation comes from practice
practice should obviously be understood
as the materialist name of the real it
would thus be appropriate to say that
the idea that symbolizes the becoming in
truth of just political ideas in history
that is to say the idea of communism
therefore comes itself from the idea of
practice from the experience of the real
in the final analysis but nevertheless
cannot be reduced to it
this is because it is the protocol not
of the existence but rather of the
exposure of a truth
in action so i mean
that sounds pretty convoluted to me but
it sounds like he's saying like that you
know you can't like talk in advance i
guess based on what you were saying matt
like
you know what is gonna be what specific
procedures are gonna be that it sounds
like he's saying you have to like it's
an articulating principle you have to
put into practice unless i'm misreading
that but no no i think you're absolutely
right i mean he shares with marx that's
why he likes the event right it's like
you have to actually bring these things
into into be being like through practice
and and seeing what happens i guess
exactly right he shares with marx and i
think this is one of the more noxious uh
influences of marxism awareness about
writing what he calls you know what
mark's called you know uh cookbooks for
the cook shops of the future or recipe
books for the cook shops of the future
right that's not our job uh you know we
should be operating at the level of
historical ontology what the hell is a
cook shop
well it's marxist the translation of
marx's phrase i don't know a restaurant
a restaurant yeah i guess an idea mill
an idea yeah and you know i have enough
respect for political theory and also
i've engaged in enough kind of uh
practical level politics to say no
sometimes it is good to have an advance
a program it doesn't need to be worked
out in all of its details and obviously
praxis is going to transform things
but i think this is also useful because
when it comes to
giving people a vision for the future
that is concrete enough that they can
invest their hopes in it uh but utopian
enough that they think could be better
than what's going on uh that's kind of
virtuous mean in my opinion like i like
the i feel that one of the problems with
leftist activism today
is precisely that it's that it's it's
it's motivated by very big vague sorry
abstract
ideas so like when we saw occupy happen
it's like oh we have this articulating
principle of like occupying it's like
we'll figure out it in practice and
guess what because they didn't have any
of that [ __ ] figured out nothing
happened because they had nothing and
it's like it's it's like so to me this
is i don't know like like it risks like
you know and i will admit i you know
it's a bit of a difficult essay and i
don't know bad use work in the past so
like i could just be misreading him but
like based on what i read here it kind
of does seem like this is you know a
version of saying like oh don't worry
about like having specific you know
demand specific just it's an
articulating principle that like you
know motivates us to be creative and
could see what happens next and i guess
every time i've seen that put into
practice where the practice is supposed
to i guess spontaneously create like the
just
situation it just becomes it just kind
of fizzles so i don't know sorry are you
wait are you saying victor like it's too
vague that
um this is the
it's basically emancipation collective
emancipation
from the capitalist state that's kind of
a too vague for you
yeah because like because yeah there's
no plan on like what's going to come
next what's the transition going to be
what institutions do you want to fight
for
what do you want to keep what do you
want to get rid of like why does one
thing work how is that how are we going
to like incentivize certain things like
like there needs to there's serious
questions that need to be like thought
about and if you you need to fight and
also like how are you what are you going
to fight for
to put the moot like leftist movement in
a better position to fight for even more
because not like i think incrementalism
is like the only way to go but at the
same time like we need to think about
like what what can we fight for that's
then going to put us in a stronger
position
to like fight for more and i think like
a good example of something would be
like a basic income is like not going to
be the end point but it's like fighting
for a basic income would then would then
enable like working class people to be
in a stronger position to be like well
[ __ ] you this job is exploiting me i
don't need this [ __ ] it's gonna make
activism stronger because it frees like
every step that can free the movement
uh will put us in a stronger position to
ask for even more later i just feel like
instead and instead it just feels like
we just want emancipation now and it's
like okay what does that even mean like
i do feel like with this thing the event
it kind of feels what you're saying is
like an all or nothing there's not
there's not a reformism in there it's
you're committed to the event the event
is unpredictable we don't know when
it'll happen but
us academic philosophers in in
institutions just have to wait for it to
happen and we'll know it when we see it
yeah it seems i agree i have i share the
sentiment that it seems a little bit abs
abstract but now the way you just said
it there almost makes it seem pseudo
religious too it's like we don't know
when it's gonna happen it's just gonna
happen and then and then the messiah is
gonna do it
he wrote
yeah it's not just pseudo-religious
that's what i'm saying he expressly
compares the event to something like a
miracle i mean he's french right i mean
he can endlessly romanticizes may 68 and
talks about it as like a heroic
miraculous time when you know everything
almost always went well right but i mean
zizik has a really good criticism
criticism of beju along those lines
that's really nicely summarized by his
criticism of occupy because zuzia said
you know i went around occupy wall
street
and i continuously asked them okay what
do you want yeah yeah yeah
and they were just like we want money to
work for people not the other way around
or we want freedom and equality now and
he said you know my god you know that
means nothing right you know
and you do kind of get a similar vibe
reading veggies work which is why i need
you think i think you need political
theory and political programs because
again you sit there and you're like okay
so i'll just wait for this miraculous
event to occur uh show fidelity to it
when it appears and then
i suppose emancipation will come it's
very very vague uh i mean wait no this
is this is not a good criticism because
badu gives plenty of examples you like
first you look to history those are your
examples
and then you have a truth procedure so
his criticism of occupy would have been
the same thing that they did not have a
truth procedure and that's why they
couldn't do anything i think that you
would say if they had
if they had a philosophical idea then
they would have known what to do no i
don't think so at all i mean he's very
expressed about the fact that you can't
know in advance uh what kinds of
emancipation that you're going to be
committed to
because it's precisely the fact that
you're disrupting the established order
of political being that opens up the
possibility of possibilities to come and
if you establish that in advance
by saying this is what we're trying to
achieve you're already precluding
the
contingency uh and the creative kind of
energies that are supposed to be yeah
but then you don't have an idea of
communism
well no i would say that i mean they did
they had an idea that they wanted the
possibility a possible new possibility
yeah but you're you're only saying the
event over and over again the defines
specifically the idea of communism as
subjective subjectivation history and
truth procedure
yeah it's subjectivation that occurs
when the event
appears and then you choose to show
fidelity to it and that's when you
become a kind of political agent that's
engaged in social transformation and all
i'm saying is that in these kind of
circumstances that really tells us
nothing about the content of what it is
that we're going to be committed to when
the open the event opens up the new
spaces of political possibilities and
that's what i think we desperately need
we need a more concrete vision of our
political future that people can
aspire to while thinking it's realistic
enough that it could plausibly be
obtained i mean my god i just finished
reading a book by tom spakette who the
jew probably hates oh yeah i love him
equality where he lists off these are
the ten things that we should do here's
how we could achieve them within the
next five to ten years none of this is
unrealistic here's five or six different
instances where we've done exactly these
things in the past yeah here's how we
can pay for it here's like how much
it'll cost like here's why like you want
he's actually arguing for like an
inheritance system where like is it
increments of every couple years or
something or it's 120 000 euros uh upon
hitting the age i think of 25 or so it's
actually pretty generous everyone would
get 120 grand at the when they hit 25.
yeah and he says you take these all
together we'd have a democratic
ecological multicultural socialism and i
can sit there and pick up that book and
say this is an agenda
it's vague enough that it can be applied
in different ways but it's concrete
enough and has enough examples that
anytime someone sits there and says
you're just pie in the sky leftists or
you can say no here's where this has
been done before successfully right and
to me
you can actually give a road map to like
progressive legislators of like what
kind of laws to pass
yeah i mean to me
sorry sorry i must interrupt here i have
to assert again what we are talking
about because you think you're right for
a critique here but there it's just your
own
predilections yeah because i mean to me
no you no no you're saying what you want
a philosopher to be but that is not what
badu believes
a philosopher is a philosopher is not
a political theorist and it sounds like
you have read at least as much bed you
as i have so you'll know
that for bad dew a philosopher has one
job only one and it is not public policy
it is laying out
truth procedures
and our listeners who are familiar with
dillo's will know he also said
philosophers have only one job qua
philosopher and that is to create
concepts and these are not unrelated but
i'm not going to derail the discussion
that way but anyway badou is not going
to give public policy advice because
that is not what philosophers do
philosophers lay out truth procedures in
aesthetics
in science in politics without without
ever doing art science or politics but
the argument made here is ultimately
about the reel itself and if you want to
do thomas piketty then go to thomas
piketty instead but he'd just say well
that isn't philosophy anymore that's
something else not like he wouldn't like
it he just that's not his
his his vision or task of what
philosophy is for yeah i mean to me
theoretically the book is far less
interesting and far less profound than
budget there's no bat about it there's
no theory of history there's no
materialism that's all the stuff that
you need but in terms of rallying people
around a cause the way somebody like
bernie sanders or aoc uh
or you know mitterand did back in france
this would be a much much more useful
book
tell me how you're saying
more than
i i would do philosophy differently if
we're up to me
i think part of the reason is that he
does think that
political theory is a kind of debased
form of philosophy
and there are a bunch of different
reasons for this one of the reasons is
again going back to marx
the problem with political theory is
that it doesn't operate at the level of
ontology right yeah truth which you know
is a criticism that you could say goes
all the way back to plato um because you
know ontology is the kind of privileged
philosophical discipline you know since
you know it just as part is editing
normative truth from the seemingly
abstract a historical point uh he thinks
that it's fundamentally problematic and
it just tends to reaffirm various
ideological presuppositions that people
already have
and i do think that there
is some validity to that criticism uh if
you're going to be a political theorist
it's absolutely incumbent upon you to
link your political theory to a
materialist account of how the world is
right now in a theory of power was that
was that just like academy award oscar
music to like stop talking that's what
it sounded like for a second
no that was just my phone ringing and i
know oh i think i might have been the
vet um
you know but i just think also that
this idea that we need to operate
primarily at an ontological level uh and
that that's more important than engaging
in political theorizing when discussing
something like the idea of prominism is
just a bad one it has never led marxism
or led uh the communist movement
to anything that's been particularly
useful and i think we'd be far better
off by yeah but who's we because he
is
again doing philosophy not well i'm
talking about his more general work
right and again yeah but his general
work is philosophical and someone else
can do the rest of the things yeah i
know but again if you look at the
article right what it talks about is a
very interesting theory of history uh
and i think it's broadly right about
things and he does talk about the need
to engage in a new theorizing about
possibilities for our political horizons
right i'm talking about elsewhere where
he describes the effort to
instantiate or describe what this future
is going to look like in any concrete
detail
as a kind of futile exercise because it
entails
politically theorizing about a future
which is not what we should be doing
because the order of being sets uh
what kind of things that we're going to
have to show faith to our towards in the
future when these events occur right and
you can take that or leave it if you
want i think we've all agreed that some
of this stuff is a little bit mystical
and i also just think that
it's not very useful right uh i don't
think that there's any reason why we
can't theorize about what a possible
socialist future is going to look like
and to try to map that out in
considerable detail and i think if we
want these events to come about
that's actually something that we should
be trying to do by inspiring people to
think that the future can look better
than the past
well that's all uh
pretty heavy critique there
i mean i would say i would say you know
when we tend to discuss these things
like the occupy movement
we immediately tend to look at what were
the internal failures and we immediately
background everything that they're
struggling against i mean there's a huge
asymmetry of power going on again in
against any of these movements whether
it's occupy whether it's even just
conferences like this i mean the state
of being the state of things now is
neoliberal capitalism and that's always
we always have to keep that in mind and
not background it and let it disappear
right the occupy movement didn't fail
because of some kind of internal failure
planning procedural issue it failed
because it's it's going against the
state and the state is by definition far
more powerful than anything that can
happen within the state and when these
people come together
out of their individual histories which
he says individual history is confined
within the state
when they come together into a kind of
event like this
there's an eruption there's an emergence
out of the ordinary
process of state history
into the universal history of the
development of humankind and which is
why today you know occupy is again one
of those symbols that's full of meaning
not one of these empty symbols like you
know it was bound to fail it's one of
these symbols that can give inspiration
to later movements and it becomes one of
these reference points of the idea of
communism as it moves forward because
again you can't reduce it to
any single thing like that as we were
saying so i mean it's it's easy to sort
of take the
i guess you i guess you know the the
corporate media line which is what
generally mediates these events to us
we'll try to explain it as internal
failures
i disagree that that's
i don't think that's a corporate media
view like i think in fact i would say in
academia what you're talking about is
very foregrounded i would say like my
critique is actually that like i think
that these like internal like the lack
of a plan is actually very backgrounded
when you're when you're in most like you
know leftist circles they want a
foreground well it's a symbolic thing
that like helps articulate the principle
further and like no one wants to talk
about
the fact that like maybe it could have
been done better and like you know
there's a great book by zainab toufeke
who's a like a turkish scholar activist
and she wrote this book twitter and tear
gas and she she's a leftist an activist
like she was at syriza she was like you
know
on the ground activist for many years
and she was there and wrote extensively
about the failures of occupy the
internal failings of it like and
critiques it and says that like a lot of
this has to do with um kind of like
leaning too heavily on technologies that
we're like we'll meet here we'll do this
but there's no on the ground
like like like building an
infrastructure which is like what
activist movements before the internet
had to do right they had to go on the
ground knock on doors build like
capacity build you know pressure on
elected officials like have a plan for
how to like push for things like like
the civil rights movement so yes like i
i'm not so i don't want to say that it's
like valueless right like i think it was
an important gesture but at the same
time like it can't that can't be its
only purpose it can't just be like this
thing that oh my god it was such a nice
gesture that we can use it's like no no
like it could have been better and like
that could have been better is an
important thing i think to to keep in
mind
yeah that reflects i mean i want to take
the event i want to take eric's side on
this because we can't just isolate
occupy from like 100 years of of
capitalist state consolidating power
you can't you can't expect so different
that's so defeatist though like like
that no that's
realist it's what it's the state yeah
total like it is this state and the
state as
with with having a lot of time huge
efforts of domestic policy of organizing
state power overseas and at home to
maintain a specific status quo
the
creation of the fbi and the cia in large
part were to deal with any disruption to
the status quo
particularly by the left and we're
talking about
a century of overthrowing
governments
without without remorse europe latin
america southeast asia and not to
mention that even even the conciliatory
policies of the american government to
give people anything at all
were done out of necessity to prevent
them from moving any further left like
you got your minimum wage what the [ __ ]
else do you want so pointing out that
occupy wall street didn't lead to any
policy reforms so it's its fault is just
for getting the massive
single-minded apparatus that built
world history this century
that's not defeatest in the slightest
it's just like
what would you expect on your on your
first how can you use the state against
itself if you like if you there are ways
i think like like history also shows
like a lot of a lot of legislation
passing a lot of things changing if done
properly and i think like having a plan
for something like a like a like
demanding a basic income or like what
this thomas piketty guy like is talking
about like i think there's ways of
actually like
um you know organizing for things that
are tangible that would then that would
then put the leftist movements in a
better position and this like refusal
and this like always using this oh my
god the state's so powerful we can't do
anything as like an excuse
so then we're only gonna fight for like
these big abstract principles
like i think it's a real problem to just
be like going after the big ideas and
not being like well what can we do
within the conditions that we're in
rather than being like okay we're going
to try for the full emancipation and
then we're just going to blame the state
being so powerful and then so it's
impossible i wasn't blaming the state
for being powerful i'm saying that this
the symbol of resistance is valuable
when it's an ant fighting against
goliath it's not david and goliath it's
an ant goliath but you could even say
that
the the bernie
swell of support was a result of that
of occupy which would be a success
towards the idea of communism
and there are still
potentialities that
that
are still unrealized there first off i
would say that i think that bernie
sanders success owed in no small part uh
to the fact that he put forward a
political program that people were
attracted to and i mean there's a reason
why fox news voters are sorry fox news
viewers applauded when he talked about
universal healthcare for all it was just
legitimately an attractive proposal but
i mean one of my objections to baja is a
nice concrete one which is that the most
successful communist party in the world
right now uh bar none right uh we're not
talking about the chinese here as the
communist party in the indian state of
kerala which has been elected by voters
consistently year after year after year
after year
and is more or less the hegemonic party
for millions of people
and the reason why they're successful is
they advance policies leftist policies
that people really liked in the state a
very good example of this is
they wanted to send more girls to school
and previous parties had just tried to
pay parents saying don't send your girls
to work in the factories that's
exploitative take this money instead and
the parents took the money and set their
girls to the factories anyway because
there's no way of enforcing that so the
chinese communist party good materialist
that they are said we need to actually
try to offer
tangible benefits to these girls to go
to school so let's just offer a free
lunch for everyone uh who goes to school
and the parents sent their kids to
school and
girl female literacy shot up in the
province
by exponential degrees you know that's
an example of a communist party
coming to power using the state to
advance policies that make people's
lives materially better and gaining
legitimacy over the long run through
instituting these kinds of reforms now
i'm not saying they're perfect they have
problems etc etc but the failure to
actually take seriously these very
concrete issues that actually make
people buy into your political program
and offering an alternative that people
can realistically say this will make my
life tangibly better is a failure of the
imagination and frankly i don't think
it's particularly marxist since if we
are going to be good marxists we should
very much be concerned with the material
conditions of people and how to improve
well i think you're obviously you're
also articulating the cia why they were
they're not worried about the french
left
yeah like like they're like that that
you know their their report they're like
yeah french intellectuals are no threat
uh yeah
exactly
compare something like this idea in bed
like one day there's gonna be a
miraculous event and we kind of tell
what it's gonna be like in advance and i
can't tell you what the institutions are
gonna look like when we do it but you
will show fidelity to it because that's
the right thing to do right it sounds
kind of mystical right and if i were a
cia agent i would sit there and be like
yeah he can go found his little church
and nothing is going to come from
yeah this and by the way we're
referencing uh plastic pills video there
uh radical theory and the cia it's a
great video where he goes through us a
report
where the cia
considered the threat
of french intellectuals um and all and
initially and basically they concluded
that uh this is way better than uh the
old communist party that was organizing
because they're they're disjointed and
they have these hyper-abstract ideas and
it's never going to lead to anything
tangible
so that's great let's let them keep
doing their little french theory this is
just a criticism of this kind of
political inclinations i tend to agree
like i said with his philosophy of
history i think that's really good his
criticism's a pagal
and i also tend to actually like his
approach to post-structuralism as well
so it's not like i'm anti-vegeta i think
he does done a lot of good things but
i mean again
we've we've come back okay from the
revolutionary position where we need to
abolish the state to the reform position
where we use the state to
structure change gradually to make
things better for people
and so we've defused the entire
thrust of this article in the whole book
i don't agree i don't agree what one
article in and second of all we know if
we've been paying attention to marx's
historical analysis and our educations
we know that people tend to vote against
their own interests because the
offerings of political parties are
always couched in all sorts of rhetoric
and there's all sorts of campaigning and
media machines and advertisement deals
involved and with the right kind of
persuasion you can get people to vote
against their own
needs right so you can't really just say
that oh well this political party in
india is succeeding because they're
doing this right well what about you
know the election of trump the recent
election of another conservative
party in ontario i think we can clearly
say if we have our head screwed on
straight that that was against the
interests of the working class and yet
it was still presented in a way that
made it more appealing than all of the
other options
so i don't think there's a one-to-one
relationship between you know
presenting a policy that will improve
the working classes conditions and
the majority of voters
involved in those situations actually
voting for the party offering those
platforms it's stupid i just want to say
that i i i reject the dichotomy between
reformism versus revolutionary like i
think maybe listeners will be surprised
to hear me say that i'm actually very
pro-revolution but the problem is my
argument is that you need to create the
material conditions to make actual
revolution possible and i think that
requires
fighting for things that puts the
working class in a stronger position to
be able to do that right now
like the risk is too high like like you
there's we don't have the material
conditions necessary to actually like
create meaningful revolutions to me like
it's a it's a false dichotomy like like
you you can't reject one and accept the
other one if you're if you're a true
leftist you have to understand like i
think that they they feed into each
other like one is the condition of the
possibility for the other i would
absolutely agree with that and i mean if
you look at most successful leftist
movements that are still considered
widely legitimate uh in many instances
the kind of reforms carried out by
socialist parties or social democratic
parties uh in western europe and in the
nordic countries weren't actually uh
catalyst for the working class kind of
disassembling and saying we've won all
the victories that we want right now
there are catalysts for pursuing more
ambitious programs uh over a long period
of time the nordic example is a really
good to get it like we're getting so far
off the topic of this book and if this
series continues to go like this baju is
a philosopher right baju is not an
economist he's not thomas piketty he's
trying to justify why the idea of
communism is correct
not the best way to go so if you want
him to be a political theorist you're
going to be disappointed because he's
not he's not a political scientist he's
a philosopher he's establishing the
conditions for revolution
philosophically which is a different
project from everything that you're
criticizing him for
sure but i mean it is fundamentally
related and i mean this is one of the
things that we're getting into because
it's not that he just said i
am not all those things
and so somebody else is going to have to
do that it's that he's often suggested
that these are not the kind of things
that we should be focusing on uh as
leftist intellectuals right uh and that
is a more substantial issue and i mean
just to eric's point right i don't think
either victor or i are saying all you
need to do is come up with the right
program and everything's going to go
together there are a lot of different
contingent circumstances you know i
worked on the ndp campaign right now i
happen to think our program was pretty
good but we had i can say this now a
[ __ ] leader just a terrible terrible
leader right who had about the charisma
of a box and
if we'd had a different leader who had
had a little bit more charisma and had a
little bit more of an attachment with
voters maybe things could have been
different you know uh doug ford say
whatever you will about him has a bit of
charisma and so i just i just want to
say though like i think you know to
bring it back to the article like i like
i think what we're discussing here
though is like what is the connection
between ideas and change or ideas and
actions right so like
you know i i like i think like i it's
related right like i think
and i just don't think that like bad use
like
i mean as far as i understand it
i i don't find like his his account and
i thought you kind of agreed with my
critique earlier pills like that it's
just overly
messianic or something or like overly
religious and it's like
you know and i think like the reason why
i don't like it is because it just makes
that connection between the idea of
communism and action
it just makes it overly mythological and
or overly uh i don't know like mystical
for me that like it doesn't seem like
it's gonna be
have a meaningful contribution now it's
a philosophical idea it's interesting
it's you know it's
um but but i you know what i thought we
were kind of talking about like but then
that that connection between like ideas
and actions but his objection okay we
were talking about something different
before the messianic thing and i'm
talking philosophically there but when
we talk
specifically about um
why he's against reformism for example
and i think eric kind of
pointed out that you're just diffusing
the argument
by making it only about this party in
india or that party elsewhere or this
party anything that can be done within
the context oh you mean like actual
events that improve people's lives where
we were politically yes
everything that happens within the
context you mean the real world yeah
whether it's those kind of bait and
switching exams where it's like hey this
improves your lives and then two years
later it all gets cut out anyway because
they've served their purpose which is to
get that party in power not really to
ameliorate the suffering it's such a
such a paranoid view of like that it's
like every every incremental thing is
just there to cement the power like i
think it's like realistic but it does
paranoia is another man's real no i mean
the world is so bad
tell that to them tens of millions of
girls in kerala who now have an
education this is exactly what i'm
talking about when he he says exactly
what you're saying that you can think of
the real world
and the real world is in lacon's terms
the imaginary and the symbolic if you
only fight in those zones you will lose
so if you're saying
girls in crawl are going to school we're
that's okay
and i know matt's not saying that but
that is not a criticism of badu's
argument because he's saying do do
whatever else i don't care about
whatever else that's not my concern
my concern is that history has to be
broken because history as it exists now
is only the history of the state and
only the history of capitals
so any reforms any reforms in there do
whatever you want they're not going to
solve anything
philosophically the view that i that i
think matt and i
are are pushing is is not that like okay
be happy with like reformism that's the
real key is actually that like i think
what maybe bad deal is missing
is that like this kind of like these
kinds of reforms
do actually create possibilities for new
possibilities like so it's not like like
philosophically like it creates
conditions for the emergence of new
events
like like i think that new events are
possible as a result of this process of
reform like so i don't think that like i
think that often there's like a straw
man
of like what reformism is which is that
like okay we'll have this reform and now
girls can go to school in whatever
karachi or whatever matt was talking
about and like now we can be happy no
it's not to be happy it's to make the
the underlying like working-class people
stronger to then precipitate something
new new possibilities it's like so and i
think that like this this rejection
actually stifles new events and new
possibilities from emerging so i think
philosophically like like i think the
objection is more philosophical than
it's been given credit for yeah and i
think that that's absolutely true and i
think there's a reason why it is that he
continuously demonstrates this nostalgia
for something like maoism right which
was a human catastrophe
and he continuously romanticizes it in a
certain way by saying well it was a
genuine break in the order of being an
event of the highest order while
ignoring the fact that millions of
people were killed by this event and
nobody even the chinese communist party
wants to go back to that contrast that
again with something that seems a little
bit more boring like the communist party
success in kerala by contrast millions
of girls now get to go to school and get
a meal and are probably going to live
because of the programs that are
instituted by this communist party which
is a step towards legitimating leftism
more broadly in a country with billions
of people right
i would see that as a vastly more
concrete step forward for the left uh
than any kind of
interview uh where you sit there and
you're saying it wasn't 60 million
people that died it was 10 million
people and we should still remember that
maoism was a break uh with capitalism
that was of world historical
significance my response to that is you
need to [ __ ] get out of paris go and
actually spend some time with these
people and ask them what kind of
communism they think is actually of more
positive world historical significance
well just to be conciliatory but doesn't
this all actually line up nicely with
but that you is saying we're we're
pointing out all these individual events
and if an event is a rupture in the
normal order of bodies and languages as
it exists in any particular situation if
that's how he defines an event and also
it's a creation of new possibilities
then an event whether it's good or bad
it's going to introduce new
possibilities if it is truly an event
whether it's
those kinds of reformist events like
you're talking about or more you know
like abrupt events like occupy or the
maoist revolution right they introduce
new possibilities and what we have to do
is we have to take those specific
singular possibilities that emerged in
particular circumstances
use our imagination to project those
into universal history which is part of
the universal history of humanity and
that's the whole procedure right with
the three elements put together the idea
is the political singular the historical
universal and the subjective which binds
it all together into a single body of
truth and that's what we have to do with
each of those individual events good or
bad they're going to introduce new
possibilities the act afterwards of
reflecting on the failures internal and
external and why it didn't work what
worked about it all those things
contribute to our imaginative
abstracting
of the things from that event and
projecting them into universal history
which is then something we can remain we
can have fidelity to those new
possibilities which were unexpected the
day before
those things happened the day before
occupy no one even knew that something
like that was [ __ ] possible and then
afterwards were like wow like that
failed gloriously but what new
possibilities for the future i am now
concerned with like that to me is the
idea it's a forward-thinking utopian
yeah it has that religious spin because
you know a lot of people in this world
today are very taken with spiritualism
and i think even rhetorically
having a religious kind of thrust is not
the worst thing you can build into your
theory even though it's got a specific
purpose right he's used saint paul to
articulate universalism so he can make
it into his idea of history which is
universal the universal history of human
humanity so i mean i don't think all of
this is necessarily a shot against it
these could be nicely integrated into
what he's saying i mean and matt here's
a here's a quotation from the article
where he says the same thing that you're
saying because you you seem to think
that he's really against these girls
getting educated in kerala
so
in this view of things the most
important ordinary action is to take
someone to a real political meeting far
from home far from their predetermined
existential parameters aka paris
um in a hostel of workers
from mali for example or at the gates of
a factory once they have come to a place
where politics is occurring they will
make a decision about whether to
incorporate or withdraw so if you were
to ask him mr badu do you want these
girls in in kerala to get educated he
would certainly say yes
because of the possibilities that it
produces yes okay good and i will say
so i agree i agree with every moment of
decision you pointed to decide to
totally withdraw i agree i think really
like my objection through this thing has
been more
um like so i'm glad that's a good
conciliatory point that you brought up
eric so so i appreciated that i think
really what i would just say is like i
think uh like the left is i think maybe
overvalues events like occupy as like
actually presenting something and
grossly undervalues kind of like like
reform events for the new possibilities
that they create that's i guess
well still agreeing totally with with
your uh with your conciliatory point
yeah i think that that's a good point to
end on and i agree uh with a lot of what
you both said now look again i want to
point out i don't hate the guy in fact i
like a lot of what he's saying in fact i
i tend to agree with his
reinterpretation uh of the this isn't
about liking or hating i just think
you're characterizing by saying pick any
good
bad you bad when they're they're they're
doing different projects it's like yeah
i did say like doing different things i
just think that sometimes badger leans a
little too heavily
on the mysticism right but the sentence
that you gave at the end of the essay is
a nice instance where he does kind of
bring it back down
a little bit
and to kind of eric's point one of the
points that i agree with badger on and
that echoes what eric said uh is bad you
does tend to say that in instances where
you see something that looked like it
might have an event and it failed uh the
best
like occupy the best wisdom uh is the
wisdom of samuel beckett who's a big fan
of uh rightly so uh which is you know
fail fail again fail better right uh and
that's not really all that different
than saying you know learn from your
mistakes uh and i think that if you look
at something like occupy
or bernie sanders campaign uh it's just
failures and that's not actually taking
anything positive from them and i think
we should right we should sit there and
say what did they do wrong what did they
do right and how can we make sure to
avoid their mistakes in the future
and we shouldn't even be just looking at
those failures like recently that chris
smalls guy
unionized an amazon warehouse it's going
on in starbucks so that's the thing
maybe we should be focusing on that i
mean that is that is some meaningful
organizing right there like that is good
stuff and that and that relieves the
immigration
just enough for people to participate
more in politics right like beyond
voting once every cycle
there's also a level of involvement that
can happen when you're you know
when your life is as a as a measure of
security to it that those things are
undoubtedly bringing to the people who
are being unionized in the starbucks and
the warehouses across the states right
now hopefully that continues but that's
not that's not the end of the struggle
obviously i don't think anyone
would think that it's an end in itself
but it's certainly a step
yeah that's right that's why he calls it
the beginning this is a horizon and
we've talked about horizon before in
terms of phenomenology but he uses that
as like the hara like just think about
the horizon it's always the limit
so his focus is always on the limit and
maybe he should be focused more on the
steps that it takes to get there but
that's the kind of what his
philosophical position is is look always
at the limit don't look at what's in
front of you
which you're calling mysticism i like
some mysticism sure i just want to say
though that you're all missing the most
important thing that came from chris
malls's efforts which is that he gave
the single best burn uh
of 2022 to jeff bezos where he pointed
out that he'd like to thank him for
going to space because while he was up
there roaming around in his rocket ship
they were down there organizing right
and if nothing else that diss alone
should secure chris malls a permanent
place in leftist history
yes
back to space with all of them
well that's a great that was that's a
good
maybe a good point to end on guys i
don't know i feel like that's a good
start good start
i think it was a good start to the
series i got a little heated sorry no
that's which is good
baju gives a summary of his own work so
i'll give this quotation and if there's
any thoughts we'll finish on that
let's recapitulate as simply as possible
thank you mr badu a truth is the
political real history even as a
reservoir of proper names
including chris smalls
is a symbolic place the ideological
operation of the idea of communism is
the imaginary projection of the
political reel into the symbolic fiction
of history including its guise as
representation of the action of
innumerable masses via the one of a
proper name
including all the amazon workers right
the the role of this idea is to support
the individual's incorporation into the
discipline of a truth procedure to
authorize the individual and his or her
her own eyes to go beyond the statist
constraints of mere survival by becoming
a part of the body of truth
so i think you're very right in terms of
we don't know what comes out of girls
being educated in kerala we don't know
what the amazon workers are going to do
with more time on their hands and more
uh hope in their hearts
but those do open up those sorts of
possibilities to go beyond what he calls
the statist constraints of history and
obviously there's a certain
constructivist thrust this argument
in a certain way right because he does
say you know truth has a fictional
structure the idea exposes truth
in a fictional structure and i'm
guessing this fictional structure
part of the imaginary projection
is
what sort of needs to be in place to
grasp the truth in a certain way there's
a certain mixing of reality and fiction
there
which makes it a kind of a kind of
constructivism
but a kind of constructivist
with realist yearnings
and it's good to have the part of the
fiction is it's good to have heroes it's
good to
like uh elevate these people to
prophetic status even because it gets
more people into the body
yeah and his account of truth is
actually very interesting and it relates
back to what you're saying eric because
he points out and this is where he's
kind of anti he's an anti-plate and his
platonus right which is that
the history of western concepts of truth
has always been that truth is singular
accounts for the whole
and
can describe a kind of totality uh and
in fact the real truth that we need to
become aware of uh
is
to expose reality as contingent multiple
uh and open to various possibilities
right and i think that's kind of an
inspiring way of taking some of the
insights to post structuralism and
turning them into a more systematic
world view something like what the liz
did and
i don't i just find the guy inspiring at
that level yeah that's a nice way
because he's trying to sort of take
these ideas of universal eternal truth
and contingency
and kind of put them together in a weird
way right because we don't want to be
fatalistic or deterministic
we want to stay open to the
possibilities in a certain way
and and there's and truth doesn't
necessarily contradict
that although it seems to when we claim
you know when we do talk about the truth
we talk about the way things are the way
things will be but we tend not to
include in truth the way things could be
and the way things could have been
yeah i can't remember where he says it
but he says that like
a naked truth displays the vulnerability
of being uh it's a sentence of his which
is very artful and very poetic uh which
you can be at points when he's not
raiding really badly uh and i think that
there's something really
inspiring about the project that he
initiated which was to try to take the
insights of post-structuralism
seriously um but not necessarily fall
into skepticism uh or the nihilism uh or
even the kind of
resignation uh that you found uh with it
uh and for that you know he deserves a
huge amount of credit um because whether
even though i don't agree with a lot of
what he says even ontologically the fact
that he opened the door to these kind of
inquiries is something that's extremely
important and he deserves
mad props for doing that yeah and i
think you're right about the sort of
quasi-mystical quasi-religious
couching of truth
and the sort of horizon that this idea
points towards i think there is
definitely that but i mean i try to
suspend my disbelief a little bit
and i try to look at that as part of the
fictional structure through which we
grasp truth as well it's a kind of
conceptual scaffolding that helps us
understand rather than
rather than the kind of you know
hardcore atheist response to that which
should just be you know it's all
nonsense i try to suspend that a little
bit when i'm reading this which i think
is necessary
yeah that's fair he's like any other
systematic thinker right you're probably
if you read him you're probably going to
find
a lot that you don't like and
a lot that you do like you just have to
kind of
cut to let yourself you have to let
yourself get taken into the system and
just like like take it up on its own
terms otherwise you're gonna you're
gonna like prevent yourself from
from learning if you go in with an
overly skeptical
attitude i think yeah and i should say
the guy's still alive and active he's
kind of like hibernating that he just
released a huge [ __ ] book recently
which pissed me off because i thought i
had read everything important by him and
now i have to go back and read that
which i'm irritated by um but you know
give him a lot of props
another book for you to review uh
yeah there you go
so i yeah no one no one here just in
case it's uh
not clear no one here is saying that
anyone needs to read bed you before they
go to organize it's definitely not it
does not matter in that sense but if
ideas are something that do matter to
you and you want to sit there and have a
construction of the world that
that means the world could look
different than it does right now that's
really what this is for it's too yeah to
create the idea yeah because the role of
philosophers in the struggle is to
clarify the important questions that we
need to ask going forward i think that's
basically paraphrasing what gjx said as
that would be the specific role of the
philosopher in this
is to yeah clarify what's important what
the questions are
and try to
distinguish them from irrelevant
questions
or at least give these questions meaning
that's that's sort of the way jesus so
we have to think of the role of the
philosopher right because it's a
collective effort requires many
different people wearing many different
hats
and
i mean the philosopher plays an
interesting role
because of what a philosopher is a
university educated
pie in the sky high falutin writer
but this
kind of proves they can still have value
or at least it it tries to argue that
they have a central value to the
struggle
all right i think we can call that
episode one of the series and maybe
we'll try to find uh one of the ones
that argues against him for the next one
but anyway
uh good episode one guys thank you
everyone out there for listening and
let's talk later
that was great let's bring this
operation to a halt
[Music]